طباخ بوتين يفاجئ العالم
بشانوت ومحطه
تتلقى ضربه صاروخيه كادت ان تتسبب بكارثه
نوويه وكييف تطلب مليون قطعه سلاح فما
الذي يجري بينما كوريا الجنوبيه تعلن
نفسها اكبر مستفيد من الحرب الاوكرانيه
وقمه سعوديه روسيه لانهاء الحرب
الاوكرانيه وموسكو ترحب وحفله الانتقام
الروسيه تبدا باكثر من 400 صاروخ
والولايات المتحده تعلن عن تجهيز ثمانين
مليار دولار لمواجهه الصين خلال الخمس
سنوات القادمه فقط
انتم تذكرون وتزورون الحقائق وكارثه اخرى
تصيب السوريين بعد الزلزال جرائم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تتواصل في فلسطين والفصائل
تتوعد بالرد الحوثيون في جوله مفاوضات
جديده وحاسمه واثيوبيا تعلن التحدي من اجل
سد النهضه الحرب الروسيه تتوسع غريب امر
هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا فتاره ينسحب
الاوكران من مناطقهم وترى ينسحب الروس لكن
الاغرب هو ان تقرر قوات موسكو الانسحاب
بعد اقتراب سيطرتهم على باخموت ايعقل هذا
الطباخ بوتين مؤسس مجموعه باجنر هو من
يطبخ هذا الامر حيث قال ان قوته مهدده
بالانسحاب من بخموت بسبب نقص امدادات
السلاح متهما وزير الدفاع الروسي وجنرالات
سياسيه اخرى بالخيانه اليكم المصدر بالفعل
هناك تصريحات
مستمره من قبل مؤسس قوات فاجنر يفقينيا
يتهم فيها الدفاع الروسيه بالتقصير
بالامدادات العسكريه ان كان البشريه او
حتى
الامداد بالذخيره بينما هنا محطه زبروج
اصبحت من دون كهرباء وذلك بعد ضربه روسيه
على المنطقه والتي تسببت بقطع شريان الخط
الرئيسي الذي يغذي المحطه لتتهم موسكو
لانها تضع العالم على حافه كارثه نوويه
بحسب وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه ليعلن الجيش
الاوكراني ان روسيا اطلقت 81 صاروخا
وثمانيه سيارات على مدن عده في الصباح
الماضي لتبدا روسيا حفله الانتقام الخاص
بها بعد تبول مجموعه اوكرانيه في العمق
الروسي لتؤكد الدفاع الروسي ان قواتها وجه
الضربه الانتقاميه واسعه باكثر من اربع
مئه صاروخ ردا على الحدودي للاوكرانيين
فعن اي ضربه يتحدثون ليوجه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني خطابه نحو وزراء الدفاع
الاوروبيين المجتمعين في السويد راجيا
منهم دعما بالهده عسكريا بانظمه دفاع جوي
ومليون قطعه من الذخيره ليرد مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبيل هناك توافق على معظم اجراءات
دعم اوكرانيا ولكن هناك اسئله لا تزال
معلقه مضيفا ان هناك حاجه لايصال حزمه
اخرى من القبائل لاوكرانيا لكن ما هي
الاسئله المعلقه يا هذا ساجيبكم انا
فالجيش الاوكراني يبحث عن مجندين جدد حيث
ان الاوكرانيين يرفضون بشكل قاطع الانضمام
للجيش وبعضهم يلجا الى طرق عده للهروب من
الخدمه العسكريه ليصبح الجيش الاوكر امام
مشكله في التعبئه العسكريه في الوقت
الراهن وفق الصحيفه يزويك الامريكي وهنا
تتضح تساؤلات بوريل فكيف
يغدقونك بالاسلحه اليس هناك من يقاتل بها
اليس كذلك يا اصدقاء وبالعوده الى المعارك
الاوكرانيه قالت الاداره العسكريه في
خاركيف ان 15 غاره روسيه ازدادفت مدينه
خاركيف ومحيطات الحرب لا تتوقف يا رفاق
فهل من هدنه قادمه لتاتي الاجابه من وزير
الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان الذي اكد
ان بلاده مستعده للوساطه لانهاء الحرب
الاوكرانيه التي تؤثر على كل دول العالم
لاسيما في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وما يحدث من
ازمات ملتهبه في المنطقه بحسب الوزير
السعودي جاء ذلك في ظل زياره للوزير
على ان العلاقات السعوديه الروسيه متصاعده
وفي تطور كبير خلال الفتره الحاليه ليقول
وزير الخارجيه الروسي
ترحب بالوسطه السعوديه لكنه اضاف لا نرى
استعدادا جديا من الجانب الاوكراني للحوار
وهنا جاء الخبر الصاعق بموعد نهايه الحرب
حيث
الضابط المتقاعد في الاستخبارات الامريكيه
ان الصراع يدخل مرحلته الاخيره وسيسحق
الجيش الروسي سلاسل التوريد لاوكرانيا
وسينتصر في الخريف مضيفا ان ذخيره كييف
اوشكت على النفاذ فيما الدعم الغربي
سيتوقف فهل وصلت الرساله نعم وصلت وها هو
منسق لاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في البيت
الابيض جون كيربي يقول ان نظام الدفاع
الجوي الامريكي لم يساعد اوكرانيا
الصواريخ الروسيه المجنحه وفق شبكه سي ان
ان ليضيف ان عجز اوكرانيا عن اعتراض
الصواريخ التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت ليس
مفاجئا ايضا هذه الصواريخ بشكل هام يصعب
اعتراضها فالوع اعتراف امريكي مسبق
بالخساره الاوكرانيه اما مدير وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
فاكد ان الاشهر الاربعه الى السته المقبله
ستكون حاسمه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا حيث سيتمكن
الجيش الروسي من تحقيق تقدم كبير في ارضها
بحسب نوفوسي وفي خضم هذه الحرب التي تدور
راحها بين الروس والاوكران ورغم عدم
تصديرها رصاصه واحده لاوكرانيا اصبحت
كوريا الجنوبيه اكثر المستفيدين من حرب
اوكرانيا حيث حققت سيئول طفره هائله في
صادراتها الاسلحه لعام 2022 اذ ارتفعت
بنسبه 140 بالمئه وصولا الى مستوى قياسي
بلغ 17 مليار دولار لتتعامل مع هذه
الصفقات بذكاء حيث لم تعادي موسكو ولكنها
باعت اسلحه للدول الاوروبيه لتعويض الدعم
لاوكرانيا لننتقل نحو ساحه اخرى للحرب حيث
اعلن وزير الدفاع البولندي ماريوش بلاشاك
بدا جيش بلاده نصب المتاريس المضاده
للدبابات على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا والطرق
المؤديه الى البلد الجار فهل وصلتم
معلومات استخباراتيه عن هجمات مستقبليه
المد الصيني يرعب واشنطن رد صيني مع كل
خطوه امريكيه واعين الامريكيين شاخصه نحو
التنين الصيني ليصدر تقرير عن مجتمع
الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان الصين تعمل على
تطوير قدراتها في مجال الاسلحه النوويه
وتعميق علاقاتيا مع روسيا لترد وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه هذا التقرير تحريف واضح
للحقائق ومليء بالافتراءات لكن الولايات
المتحده لا تتوقف ومن اجل مواجهه الصين في
الخمس سنوات المقبله طلب البنتاغون من
الكونغرس تمويلا كبيرا لقوات المحيط
الهادئ لعام 2024 بحوالي
15.3 مليار دولار وبواقع اكثر من ضعف ما
طلبه لعام 2022 ليصل المبلغ نحو اكثر من
80 مليار دولار للاربع سنوات التاليه بحسب
بوليتيكو فعن اي انفاق نتحدث وما كل هذا
الرعب الامريكي من اصحاب العيون الضيقه
الاحداث والتطورات دعت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه خروف الولايات المتحده
الى الرد بشكل بناء على دعوات كوريا
الشماليه لوقف المناورات في المنطقه من لم
يمت بسبب الزلزال يظل الموت اقرب اليه لكن
هذه المره بسبب الكوليرا الذي تفشى بين
نحو واحد وخمسين الفا في مخيمات الشمال
السوري مع وفاه 23 شخصا حتى الان الا
تستحون يا تجار الحروب الم يحن الوقت بعد
لتنتهي حرب سوريا وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
تعلن ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقتحمت
اربعه فلسطينيين داخل مركبتهم في بلده جبع
لتتوعد الفصائل الفلسطينيه برد موجه بينما
ادان الهجوم الاتحاد الاوروبي في بيان
رسمي معربا عن قلقه البالغ ازاء تزايد
العنف في فلسطين المحتله مطالبا بوقف
الاستيطان ومنع عن المستوطنين ومحاسبه
الجناه وكيف يتم محاسبتهم بعد ان اعلن
وزير الدفاع الامريكي عن التزامهم الكامل
بحمايه الكيان الاسرائيلي وحمايه امنه من
اي اعتداء فلتنظر لفلسطين كما ينظر الغرب
لاوكرانيا ولا تهرول للتطبيع واللي على
راسه بطحه يحسس عليها كما يقولها المصريون
وبشان مصر الخارجيه الاثيوبيه تتحدث نهر
النيل نهر افريقي ويجب حل الخلافات بشانه
في البيت الافريقي مؤكده لاستمرار اديس
ابابا في استكمال سد النهضه توجه وفد
اللجنه الوطنيه لشؤون الاسرى التابعه
للحوثيين الى جنيف للمشاركه في جوله جديده
من المفاوضات اليمنيه حول ملف الاسرى
والمعتقلين بولندا تتحضر كساحه محتمله
للحرب القادمه فهل تتوسع الحرب ام ان
وارسوس تتجنب نيرانها
[موسيقى]